[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
Paris quand un amour fleurit ça fait
pendant des semaines le cœur qui se
sourit tout ça par SC à
Paris au
printemps sur lestoile les girouettes
don défond les coquettes avec le premier
vent qui passe indifférent non
chalant car le
vent quand il vient à Paris n'a plus
qu'un seul souci c'est d'aller musarder
dans tous les beaux quartiers de
Paris le
soleil qui est son vieux copain est
aussi de la fê comm de collégien ils sen
Bont en gogette dans
Paris et la main dans la main ils vont
sans se frapper regardant dans Chemin s
Paris à
changer il y a
toujours des taxis en maroute qui vous
chargent tant fr d'avant le
stationnement où il y a encore l'gent
des
taxis au café on voit n'importe qui qui
boit n'importe quoi qui parle avec ses
mains et qu' là depuis le matin au
café
il a la
scène à n'importe quelle heure elle a
ses visiteurs qui la regarde dans les
yeux ce sont ses amoureux à la
scène et il y a
ceux ceux qui ont fait leur lit près du
lit de la scène et qui se lavent à midi
tous les jours de la semaine dans la
scène et les autres ceux qui en ont
assez parce qu'ils en ont vu trop et qui
veulentoublier alor chet àau mais la
scène
elle préfère voir les jolis bateaux se
promener sur elle et au fil de son eau
jouer au Caravel sur la
scène les
ennuis il y en a pas qu'à Paris il y en
a dans le monde entier oui mais dans le
monde entier il y a pas partout Paris
pleennui à
Paris au 14 juillet à la lueur des
lampions on danse dans les rues on danse
dans les rues dans les
rues depuis qu'à Paris on appr pris la
Bastille dans tous les quartiers et à
chaque carrefour il y a des gars et il y
a des filles qui sur les pavés sans
arrêt nuit et jour font des tours et des
tours à
Paris
et bien au revoir